Transcriber: Gözde Alpçetin
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Başarının formülünü
genelde nasıl özetlerler?
Hayal kurmak, motivasyon,
çok çalışmak gibi.
Ama bence burada ufak bir detayı
kaçırıyoruz ki o da cesaret.
Peki insan nelerin karşısında
cesur durmak durumunda kalır?
Kalp kırıklıkları, haksızlıklar, maalesef.
Size desem ki, en son ne zaman
haksızlığa uğradınız diye
muhtemelen cevap vermekte
çok gecikmezsiniz.
Belki, biraz önce
burada biri sizin yerinize oturdu.
Belki, çok sevdiğiniz birinin
size yalan söylediğini öğrendiniz.
Kim bilir?
Dünya maalesef harika bir yer değil
ve haksızlıklar sadece
bazı insanların başına gelmiyorlar ama
biz, kocaman egolarımızın arkasında
başımıza gelen çaresizliklere
şöyle cevaplar veriyoruz:
Bu nasıl benim başıma gelir
ve ben bunu hak edecek ne yaptım, gibi.
Aslında hayatımızı ve başarımızı
başımıza gelen bu talihsizliklerin değil,
bu durumlara karşı sergilediğimiz tavrın
belirlediğini unutmamak lazım.
Benim hayat tarafından haksızlığa
uğradığımı düşünmem çok küçük yaşta oldu.
Babamı kaybettiğimde, küçük bir çocuktum
ve hayatım boyunca sürecek bu hüznü
acaba nasıl biraz hafifletebilirim
diye düşündüğümde
Darüşşafaka’nın sınavlarına
girmek istediğimi fark ettim, o yaşta.
Sınavı kazandıktan sonra okula gittim
ve kendimi koşa koşa koroya yazdırdım.
Neden böyle bir şey yaptım peki?
Çünkü çocukluğumdan beri
şarkı yazıyordum aslında
ve şarkı yazmak benim için
hayatımda duygularımla
başa çıkabilmemin bir yöntemiydi.
Orada çok güzel arkadaşlıklar
edindim Darüşşafaka’da.
Bu sırada hemen bir özet geçmek istiyorum.
Darüşşafaka, anne ya da babası
erken yaşta vefat etmiş çocukların
sınavla seçilerek alındığı,
İngilizce dilde eğitim veren
bir özel okul ve yatılı okul.
Ben de evci öğrenciydim.
Evci ne demek?
Hafta sonları evine giden öğrenci demek.
Fakat eve gittiğimde de
çok huzurlu bir ortam yoktu, maalesef.
O dönemin entelektüel olarak kabul gördüğü
ve normalize edildiği
bir alkol problemi yaşanıyordu evde
ve ben küçük bir çocuk olarak bunu
hak etmek için ne yapmış olabilirim diye
tabi ki düşünüyordum.
Dedim ya dostluklar edinmiştim
okulda diye,
yaralarımız ortaktı.
Birbirimizle konuşup
yaralarımızı hafifletmeye çalışıyorduk.
Fakat o da nesi,
orta son sınıfta arkadaşlarım,
çok sevdiğim kardeşlerim okuldan atıldılar
ve ben, maalesef, yalnız kaldım.
Talihsiz olaylar peşimi bırakmıyordu.
Çok sevdiğim arkadaşlarımdan
bir tanesinin bir telefonla
hayatına son verdiğini öğrendim.
Maalesef, gençliği
böyle bir son durak gibiydi.
Kabus gibiydi ve ben bu kabustan
uyanamıyor gibi hissediyorum kendimi.
İsmini zikretsem burada
maalesef gözyaşlarıma
hakim olamayacağım insanların
cenazeleri kalkıp durdu önümden hep.
Neden ben diye soruyordum kendime.
Peki gelelim üniversite zamanına.
Üniversite zamanında neler oldu?
Ben %100 burslu bir şekilde
çok sevdiğim bir üniversiteyi kazandım.
Yetmedi, sonrasında da bir yetenek
sınavıyla konservatuvarı kazandım filan.
Dedim ki artık hayatım değişiyor.
Kaderimin iplerini ben elime alacağım.
Bu da bu arada acayip
egoyla alakalı bir şey olsa gerek.
Ben üniversiteye devam ederken
bir yandan da çok iyi bir şeyin, grubun,
bir kadın grubunun solistliğine başladım.
Her şey çok yolunda gidiyor gibi
geliyordu bana.
Dedim ya böyle
acayip özgüvenim gelmişti filan.
Derken o sene ben merdivenlerden düştüm
ve belimi kırdım.
Bir yerinizi kırınca
ne der insanlar size çevrenizdeki?
Kırık değildir o. Kırık olsa duramazsın.
Bana da öyle söylediler.
İki hafta filan sürdü
belimin kırık olduğunu anlamaları.
Ama artık biraz geçti
ve kemik kaynamaya başlamıştı, maalesef.
O yüzden sakat kalıp kalmayacağımın
garantisi de yoktu.
Böyle Frida Kahlo gibi yataklarda
korseyle yatmak durumunda kaldım.
Şimdi burada bir küçük es verelim,
burada duralım.
Biraz da size aşktan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Çünkü hızlı bir şekilde
eğitim hayatımı geçtim.
Bence en çok haksızlığa uğranılan
konu da bu.
Çünkü en çok şarkı burada var, değil mi?
Desem ki size
hiç aramızda aldatılan var mı?
Elini kaldırmak isteyen kaldırabilir.
Kimse aldatılmamış, harika.
Hiç aldatan var mı aramızda desem?
Birisi kafasını kaşıyor ama.
(Gülüşmeler)
Evet, enteresan
çünkü genelde aldatılan var mı deyince
böyle eller kalkar.
Aldatan var mı deyince
hiç kimse kaldırmaz elini.
Ya sanki bunlar
böyle bir tarikatlar, değil mi?
Belli mevsimlerde özellikle
böyle iniyorlar şehre,
insanları aldatıp aldatıp
sonra kaçıp gidiyorlar
görmedim, duymadım, bilmedim şeklinde.
Bu tarikata üye olduğunu düşündüğüm
ilk aşkımdan bahsedeyim size.
Ben de ona yakın olabilmek uğruna
dizi dizi yalanlar söylemiştim.
Bunlardan bir tanesi yaşımı büyüterek
bir mağazada
satış danışmanlığına başlamıştım.
Fakat çok kısa bir süre sonra
bu tertemiz aşkın
bir uyuşturucu bağımlısı
olduğunu öğrendim.
Taksim’in arka sokaklarında
baliciler tarafından kovalanıyorum
ve hüngür hüngür ağlıyorum.
Fakat ağlama sebebim,
bu öğrendiğim gerçekler
ya da geçmişimin
bu kadar travmatik olması değil.
Ben o gün, aldatıldığımı öğrendiğim için
ağlıyorum, maalesef.
Bir diğer aşka geçmek istiyorum, ki o da
bundan çok çok daha parlak değil.
Bu seferki aşkımda da
sahneye çıktığımda şort giydiğim zaman
arkasını dönen protesto etmek için
ve dans derslerine katılmamı istemeyen
ve yeterince sinirlenirse aslında
beni böyle duvara çarpma yetkisini
kendinde gören bir aşk
bana göre o zamanlar tabii ki.
Bu insanın Türkiye’nin en iyi okullarında
okumuş olduğunu da
söylemeden geçemeyeceğim.
Eğitim yalnızca maalesef cehaleti alıyor.
İnsan prematüre hareketlerine
hakim olabildiği kadar insan oluyor.
Bunu da söylemek isterim.
Hemen geri gidiyorum.
Söylemiştim ya belim
kırık bir şekilde yatıyorum.
Her şey yolunda gidiyor.
Belim dışında
ve benim hiç ayakta duramamam dışında.
Konserlere çıkmam lazım.
Ben ne yapacağım peki?
Yalnızca tuvalete gidebilme iznim vardı.
Ailemde herkes
çalışmak zorunda olduğu için
yine yalnız bir dönemimdeydim.
Aynaya doğru her gün böyle giderken
bakıyorum, diyorum ki
Hazal, sakat kalacağını düşünerek
şu köşede ağlayabilirsin hayatın boyunca
ya da kalmayacağını düşünerek
şarkılarına çalışmaya devam edebilirsin
ve ben bir azimle konserlere çıkmaya
devam ettim belimde korseyle.
O gün gerçekten hiç kimse anlamadı
benim neden böyle kazık gibi durduğumu.
Ama iki saat boyunca
sahne üzerinde kalabilmek
benim için çok önemli bir şeydi o zaman.
Doktorlar bana dediler ki
işte dans edemezsin,
muhtemelen bir daha sahneye çıkamazsın
ya da işte pilates, yoga filan yapamazsın.
Hepsini yaptım.
Bunu gurur duyarak söylüyorum
ama şöyle hepsini yaptım.
O kadar korkarak yaptım ki.
Yani cehaletin böyle cesaretle
birleşik bir şey olduğu söylenir genelde.
Hani cahil cesareti diye bir şey vardır.
Halbuki bence çok yanlış biliyoruz.
Çünkü cesaret insanların
korkularına rağmen bir şeyleri yapmasıdır
ve oradaki “rağmen”
gerçekten bence çok çok önemlidir.
Peki gelelim kariyere, işe, güce.
Şimdi ünlü bir pop starın,
ve popüler olmak için
ben böyle şeylere katılmışım işte,
“audition”lara katılmıştım,
sesimi beğenmişler filan.
Son dakika artık
bir prova daha son yapacağız
ve ondan sonra turneye çıkacağız beraber.
Ben çok mutluyum.
Sonra son dakika böyle
benden çok daha işveli, cilveli,
bıcır bıcır bir hanımefendi gelip
benim bayağı işimi elimden aldı.
Yanlış anlaşılmasın,
kesinlikle kadınlara değil buradaki,
o kadının özelinde de değil benim öfkem.
Ama erkek egemen düzene
ve yozlaşmış iş ahlakına
çok sinirlenmiştim, hala da sinirliyim.
Ben tabi yoluma devam ettim.
Hemen ardından Dream TV geldi,
Dream TV’ye
sürekli başvurularda bulunuyorum.
İşte beni alsalar da
ben de sunucu olsam diye.
Aylarca aramamışlar filan.
Bir gün telefon çalıyor.
Telefonu açıyorum,
Dream TV’den bana diyorlar ki
deneme çekimine gelebilir misin, Hazal?
Diyorum ki yani tabi ki gelirim filan.
Telefonu kapatıyorum
ama ben neredeyim o sırada?
Las Vegas’tayım.
Peki Las Vegas’ta ne yapıyorum?
“Kiosk”larda oje satıyorum,
böyle “Let me see your nail”
filan diye insanlara.
Zar zor biriktirdiğim “Work and Travel”
parasıyla Las Vegas’tayım o sırada.
Ama gitmem de lazım
çünkü istiyorum Dream TV’yi.
Tamam diyorum, geleceğim.
Erkene bir uçak ayarlıyorum
ve Bağcılar’daydı Dream TV’nin stüdyoları
Kanal D’nin biliyorsunuzdur.
Las Vegas’tan Bağcılar’a
bir yolculuk başlatıyorum.
Bu yolculuk esnasında benim telefonum,
cüzdanın, çantam filan her şey çalınıyor
ve ben deneme çekimine gidemiyorum.
Yani kaderimi değiştireceğim,
bir türlü değiştiremiyorum.
Anlattığımda hala sinirlendiğim
başka bir şey var.
O da bir animasyon filminin
seslendirmesini yapacağım,
yine çok mutlu ve heyecanlıyım.
Bu sefer olacak filan.
Görüşmede son noktadayız artık.
İşin sahibiyle toplantıya gidiyorum.
Bu iş sahibi beyefendinin
gelirken bana hediye olarak
iç çamaşırı getirdiğini gördüm
ve tabi çamaşırı yere atıp
bayağı oradan uzaklaştım.
Koştum filan ama
o sırada aklıma şey geldi:
Aaa acaba bu hani
bir kamera şakası olabilir mi?
Çünkü yani hiç akla yatkın bir şey değil.
Tabi etrafta kamera yoktu
ve bu bir kamera şakası değildi.
Ben de işi alamamıştım.
Ben o dönem her şeyden çok bunalmıştım.
Çünkü o kadar çok böyle şey oldu ki
kariyerimde, hayatımda.
Erkekler için de
başka zorluklar olacak muhakkak.
Ama hanımlar, sizin için gerçekten
bu dünya çok kolay bir yer değil.
Lütfen, kendiniz olmaktan ve hakkınızı
savunmaktan vazgeçmeyin derim.
Bana göre huzurlu olma fikri sanatçı olma
fikrinden daha baskındı o dönem
ve ben her şeyimi, kariyerimi,
tırnaklarımla kazıdığım kariyerimi bırakıp
Karayipler’e gitme kararı almıştım.
İşimden istifa ettiğim gün cebimde
ertesi ayı çıkaracak kadar bile
gerçekten para kalmamıştı.
Senelerce canlı yayın
sunmuştum televizyonda
ve hiçbir maddi güvencem yoktu.
Arkadaşlarımla imece usulü para topladık.
Ben gidip kendimi
şeflik kursuna yazdırdım.
Sonrasında krediyle almış olduğum
arabamı sattım
ve kalan parayla
gemicilik kursuna yazıldım.
Koca bir sırt çantası
ve cebimde biraz umutla
Karayipler’e karın tokluğuna
yatlarda çalışmaya gittim.
Bir gün Hazi Hazi’yken öbür gün Miço’ydum
ve hiç kimseydim gerçekten.
Bir dönem o bana
çok büyük bir mutluluk vermişti,
hiç kimseyim ve yine de saygı duyuluyorum
sadece insan olduğum için diye.
Bana dediler ki
üniversite diplomanı ne yapacaksın,
Pasifik’in derinliklerine mi
gömeceksin diye.
Dedim ki olabilir.
Sonrasında bu yorucu hayatın
belki de bir karşılığı olarak, bilmiyorum,
ben de bir sığınacak liman aradım.
Ben de artık kafamı birisinin omzuna
koysam da biraz orda dinlesem diye.
Çok aşık oldum,
çok çok aşık olduğum kişiyle de evlendim.
Fakat evlendiğim bu kişinin benim
zannettiğim kişi olmadığını öğrendiğimde
artık hemen hemen her şey için çok geçti
ve her şeyimi kaybetmiştim.
Kariyerimi, özgüvenimi,
en önemlisi de gerçekten benliğimi
ve özgüvenimi kaybetmiştim.
Yine bu hayatın sonucunda anksiyete,
hastalık hastalığı, insomnia gibi
mental problemlerle
kendimi bildim bileli mücadele ettim.
En yakınlarım bile bazen görmediler,
duymadılar, bilemediler.
Peki ben size deseydim ki,
hayatımı böyle tersten anlatsaydım.
Merhabalar, ben Hazal Kazancı.
Dimi çünkü TEDx öyle bir yer.
Beverly Hills’te,
Los Angeles’ta oturuyorum.
Bundan öncesinde 5 yıl Hawaii'de yaşadım.
Bağımsız sanatçıyım,
200′den fazla şarkım var.
Yurt dışında şeflik yaptım.
Kendi şirketimi kurdum.
MBA gibi, Hollywood gibi yerlerden çıkma
starlara catering servisi verdim.
Dünyanın en büyük yaz şovunda
en iyi şef ödülünü aldım
ki ben de gerçekten hala şoktayım.
Reigenz ile dünyanın en büyük
oditoryumlarında sunuculuklar yaptım.
Madison Square Garden gibi,
Staples Center gibi.
Dream TV’de 5 yıl canlı yayın sundum.
Inna’yla, Akon’la, 50 Cent’le
röportajlar gerçekleştirdim.
Rock’n Coke’da canlı yayın sundum.
Binlerce kişilik festivallerde
performans sergiledim, sahne aldım.
Hawaii radyolarına konuk olan
ilk Türk sanatçı bendim.
Hatta Twitter’da TT bile oldum.
Bana göre başarılarımın
en önemlilerinden bir tanesi de
o dönem Karayipler’e giderken
ağabeyime emanet ettiğim kedim Luna’yı
sonunda bir düzen kurarak
yanıma almayı başardım.
O zaman ne düşünecektiniz?
Ne kadar başarılı biri olduğumu.
İşte bizim toplumumuz maalesef
gidilen hedefi görüyor hep.
Yani sonucunda ne oluyor ona bakıyor.
Bu esnada neler yaşanıyor?
Bizler hangi fırtınalarla yüzleşmek
zorunda kalıyoruz?
Başımıza neler geliyor?
Bunu çok fazla araştırmıyoruz.
Konfor alanımızda kalmayı seviyoruz biraz
ve çok azımız
bizim cesaret edemediğimiz şeyleri
cesaret eden insanları
alkış ile biliyoruz, maalesef.
Bu alandan çıkan insanlara
birazcık kulp takmayı seviyoruz aslında.
Fakat başarısızlıkların,
düşmelerin, kalkmaların
insan hayatında ne kadar önemli tecrübeler
olduğundan kimse bahsetmiyor.
Her şeyi en kısa zamanda,
en iyi şekilde yapmak istiyoruz
ve sürekli kendimizi
başkalarıyla kıyaslıyoruz.
Ama hayat öyle bir yer değil.
Hastalık var, sağlık var,
şimdilerde Covid var.
Ne bileyim; aldatmalar, aldatılmalar var.
Kalbimizin kırılacağı gerçeğiyle
yüzleşmemiz lazım.
Başarısız olabileceğimiz gerçeğiyle
Brené Brown’un dediği gibi herkes
bu arenada şampiyon olmak istiyor
ama kimse bu tozlu topraklı yollarda
savaşmak istemiyor.
Beni TEDx’e çağırdıklarında
acaba beni niye davet ettiler diye
açıkçası düşündüm.
Yani yurt dışında nasıl yaşanır,
onu mu soruyorlar?
YouTube’u açtığınız zaman bir sürü video
görebiliriz bu konuyla ilgili.
Sonra dedim ki:
Hımm, galiba benim buradaki görevim
beni dinleyecek olan kişileri
biraz kirletmek.
Yani bu arenadan, bu sahadan bahsetmek
ve korkularınıza rağmen
size buraya gelin demek.
Çünkü biliyorum ki
hepinizin aklında bir hayal var.
En azından bir fikir var.
Ama korktuğumuz için,
tereddüt ettiğimiz için,
yadırganırız belki diye
bu durumu gerçekleştiremiyoruz
ve başlayamıyoruz bile aslında.
Yine dediğim gibi, korkularımıza rağmen
eğer cüret edebilirsek,
cesaret edebilirsek
bunca olaydan sonra,
bakın ben şu an burada duruyorum
ve size bunları anlatıyorum.
Aklınızdaki o şey ne ise,
evet, biraz yalnız kalacaksınız bu esnada
ama sonrasında karşınıza öyle insanlar
çıkacak ki doğru kafaya geldiğiniz zaman
onlar size çok yardımcı olacaklar
ve bu insanları önceden
tanımıyor bile olabilirsiniz.
Benim hayatıma öyle insanlar girdi ki
gerçekten haklarını ödeyemeyeceğimi
düşündüğüm şekilde bana yardım ettiler.
Lütfen, biraz daha kendinize
ve etrafınızdaki insanlara güvenin.
Gerçekten hayata bir kere geliyoruz.
Cesaret ve cüret etmenizi
ben size tavsiye ediyorum.
Başta size demiştim ki
şarkılar yazıyorum diye.
Ben de başa çıkabilmenin
hayatta bir yöntemi olarak
bu konuyla alakalı da
bir şarkı yazdım aslında.
Sizlerle onu paylaşmak isterim.
Umarım beğenirsiniz.
(Alkış)
Ah ne masumdum
Yaktılar beni cayır cayır
Yoktu limanım saklanacağım
Anlamıyorsun
Girmiyor huzur kapıdan içeri
Olsun diyorum
Basmayacağım geri, tam gaz ileri
Hiç yara almadım diyen var mıdır?
İnsan kalbe
doğuştan dağlanır
Haksızlık, kalpsizlik
evet bu hep içime içime dert oldu
Ama susmak
Kim demiş bu kız yoruldu?
Aşık oldum yanlış adama
Ödüyorum
Bitmedi dertler, çektiğim keder
Aşk yine de güzel
Başına gelenin
kimdi suçlusu diye soruyorsun
Küçükken bebeğim
ne görüyorsan onu oluyorsun
Hiç yara almadım diyen var mıdır?
İnsanın kalbe
doğuştan dağlanır
Haksızlık, kalpsizlik
evet bu hep içime içime dert oldu
Ama susmak
Kim demiş bu kız yoruldu?
(Alkış)